نعم ، حسنًا ، الوقت الذي كنت فيه داخل
أكبر قدر من المال في المدينة التي حاولت
رميها كثيرًا مثلما ذهبنا للتو عندما تكون
جيدًا على الإطلاق
في المرحاض ربما بضع ثوانٍ
للعيش عندما تحول
إلى باب المرحاض و  لقد بدأوا في إطلاق
النار وقلت ما لديهم من نقود
كانت قد ضاعت ، وواصلوا إطلاق النار
على هذه النافذة الصغيرة أو حاولوا
ذلك بعد ذلك كنت صعبًا للغاية لكنني حطمت
النوافذ في طريق الهروب من الحريق عندما
قفزت للتو في النار  هذا كان آخر
قيل إنه مثل باب آخر وأكثر
ما يرون الناس يطلقون النار
من داخل المسجد وفي ذلك الوقت
يقفزون ولا يطيعون الاستمرار في
القتال ، لقد امتدوا فقط
من البداية وذكروا هذا أي شخص
يطلقون النار منه  هناك وهم
فقط معظم الأشخاص في
البداية لم أر أيًا من
الزوايا التي رأيتها للتو استمر في إطلاق النار
وعندما قفزت في النافذة
بعد أن توقف هناك شخصان